Donc on arrête, c'est ça ?
Ben...
Ouais, c'est mieux non ?
Lola,
Est-ce que tu veux bien qu'on reste amis ?
Ouais ...
Ouais ok mais ...
Alors t'es stressé ?
Ben ouais, un peu ouais.
Rester amis avec son ex c'est pas ...
Oui, puis ça foire souvent.
Cool ...
Merci mec c'est cool de ...
... se sentir soutenu, c'est bien.
Je t'en prie, tu déconnes ou quoi ...
Non mais votre ami à raison,
ça foire souvent.
Eh ben nickel !
Merci les gars, vous m'aidez vachement, c'est cool.
Top.
Ouais, tu vas en chier ouais ...
C'est gentil d'être là papa.
Avec plaisir, c'est la moindre des choses.
Ma fille qui a la maturité de rester amie avec son ex.
Tu sais qu'avec ta mère on n'a pas eu cette intelligence là quand on a divorcé.
Oui.
D'ailleurs je suis étonnée que vous ne vous soyez toujours pas battus.
Moi aussi ma puce.
Moi aussi ...
Si nous sommes réunis aujourd'hui,
c'est pour célébrer la fin d'une
relation amoureuse,
mais aussi
la naissance d'une amitié sincère.
Thomas Bertrand,
acceptes-tu de prendre pour amie
Lola Maliani,
de ne pas lui envoyer de texto lui demandant de venir chez toi le soir
parce que tu te sens seul
et que tu es complètement bourré,
de serrer la main de son nouveau mec
sans avoir envie
de le frapper au visage
et d'être toujours présent
malgré tout ?
Je le veux.
Comment tu vas galérer !
Chut, ça va !
Lola Maliani,
acceptes-tu de prendre pour ami
Thomas Bertrand,
de lui faire la bise à plus de quatre centimètres de ses lèvres,
de ne pas être jalouse
quand tu verras la photo de sa nouvelle meuf
et d'être
toujours présente
malgré tout ?
Ben oui bah je le veux ...
Si
quelqu'un s'oppose à cette union,
qu'il le dise maintenant
ou se taise à jamais.
Moi !
Moi je m'y oppose.
Amandine ?
Mais c'est qui ?
Je suis sa petite amie.
T'as pas perdu de temps mon salaud !
C'est clair.
Bon écoute,
moi je suis pas chaude, hein,
pour que vous restiez potes
parce que vraisemblablement vous avez vécu des trucs très intimes ensemble
donc ...
non.
Non non,
moi j'y arriverai pas.
Hum ...
Alors,
je me permets que la cérémonie soit
interrompue
pour poser une petite question.
Comme t'es plus avec Lola,
est-ce que je peux la draguer ?
Ben ...
bof.
Attends euh ...
comment ça "ben bof" ?
Bah ouais, pourquoi "bof" ?
Non mais c'est bizarre quoi ...
Et puis c'est Loïc quoi ...
T'as vraiment envie de sortir avec un mec pareil ?
Non mais non, évidemment que non.
Mais enfin là c'est un peu abusé.
Je te signale que si on reste amis,
t'auras pas à donner ton accord si je veux baiser avec un connard du genre.
Yes ...
Euh, en fait je suis juste là
donc j'entend un peu tout ce qui est injure, "connard", tout ça ...
Bon, Thomas moi ça me saoule
alors soit tu la vois plus
soit nous aussi on reste amis.
Alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Et du coup avec elle ...
Ta gueule.
Alors,
ce que je propose
c'est que,
on commence par elle,
et après on finit avec vous.
Ok ?
Ils se compliquent quand même vachement la vie les jeunes.
Pardonne-moi, c'est à moi que tu parles ?
Ben évidemment.
À qui tu crois que je parles ?
Ah non mais,
depuis dix ans je suis habitué à ce que tu t'adresses à moi en me traitant
de sac à merde donc je suis un peu surpris.
Ça va ...
Non mais tu trouves pas qu'ils en font tout un foin pour rien là ?
T'as la mémoire courte ...
Nous aussi on en a fait tout un foin quand on s'est séparés.
Genre quoi ?
T'as quand même essayé de me couper les burnes avec un sécateur.
Sécateur que m'avait offert ton père pour mes 32 ans.
C'est bien que ça te fasse marrer.
C'est bien.
Moi je suis pris de panique à chaque fois que je passe devant un Jardiland
mais c'est bien que ça te fasse marrer.
... et d'être toujours présente
malgré tout ?
Oui.
Je vous déclare
"potes"
par les liens sacrés de l'amitié.
Vous pouvez vous faire la bise.
Wouaw !
On est sur une très bonne ambiance là.
Bon j'avoue, c'était chelou.
Mais on va s'habituer non ?
Bon vas-y, on réessaie.
Non, ta main.
Quoi "ma main" ?
Bah ta main sur ma cuisse ...
Oh pardon !
Euh...
Non là c'est bizarre.
C'est bizarre ...
C'est encore chelou.
C'était encore chelou, oui on est d'accord.
Mais peut-être que c'est pas une bonne idée qu'on reste amis.
Si on est plus amoureux et qu'on peut pas être potes,
la solution c'est peut-être de plus se voir.
Bah ouais mais tu vas me manquer.
Ben toi aussi tu vas me manquer,
mais au bout d'un moment on n'a pas dix milles solutions.
Si ?
Du coup on fait ça ?
Ouais donc
clairement on pouvait pas rester potes.
Pourquoi ?
Ben parce que je sens ton érection sur mon genou.
Ouuuuuf ... Exact.
Ouais.
Je ...
Tu bandais.
... qu'il parle maintenant
ou se taise à jamais.
Je vous déclare "potes"
par les liens sacrés de l'amitié.
Vous pouvez faire la bise à votre ex.
Faudrait peut-être qu'on fasse comme eux.
Genre quoi  ?
Bah attendre que ça passe.
L'amitié,
hum ?
Du coup,
alors elle est vieille,
je suis jeune et plutôt beau gosse,
ok.
Mais,
est-ce que ya moyen avec elle ?
Ah ben je sais pas, vous voyez avec elle.
Alors ?
Bah oui ...
Évidemment, le majeur.
Je comprends.